[Music]
it was three days after the hurricane
that carolyn saw it
the power had only just come back on
there wasn't much damage to the house
itself
just a few shingles blown off and tossed
into the neighbor's yard
branches and wet leaves scattered like
yarrow sticks
she hadn't done any cleaning up out
there hadn't added to the chorus of
rakes and chainsaws that seemed to float
into her windows at every hour of the
day or night
she'd never been much for gardening and
since her office had been closed like
pretty much everything else in town for
the three days that the electricity had
been out
she'd mostly been sitting around reading
or listening to the battery-powered
radio
sweating from the sunshine in the
daytime and from the lit candles after
darkness fell
she ate a lot of granola bars and cold
pop-tarts and potato chips
feeling vaguely sick at the end of the
first day
but today the power had flickered back
to life the television bleeding suddenly
outed her at an impossible volume and
she felt the need to do something
even if that something didn't involve
going outside and waiting around in the
depressing piles of downed
tree limbs she decided to clean the
house
it was while she was vacuuming in the
spare room the one with all the junk
heaped in it because there was nowhere
else in the small house to put it
that she glanced up and out the window
behind the house just as it had always
been
was a scraggly backyard that extended
maybe 20 feet from the door at the rear
culminating in a dispirited chain-link
fence the fence itself held off an
intimidating wall of tangled vines and
branches
so thick that nothing could be seen
through them except for more foliage
growing deeper and darker in hue as it
receded from her line of sight
carolyn had never ventured out into the
wilderness beyond the fence
had never even cut back the growth it
wasn't her property back there after all
and it was probably full of snakes and
old appliances and christ knew what else
but now due to the judicious pruning
caused by the 85 mile per hour winds of
hurricane edgar
carolyn found that she could see through
the vines just a little
she could see that there was something
back there something white and
unquestionably human-made
she turned off the vacuum cleaner and
stepped closer to the window squinting
for a better look
she couldn't see much the branches were
still looped and twined in every
direction
and now there were newly fallen trunks
listing this way in that
but after a few minutes of adjusting her
vision she realized
that what she was looking at was part of
a wall
how do you like that she thought there's
another house back there in the woods
it was entirely possible for that to be
true she'd only moved into the
neighborhood less than a year ago
the taj mahal could be back there for
all she knew of course she couldn't
remember ever seeing anyone walking
around or hearing anything like voices
or a car engine
and come to think of it how would a
person living back there be able to come
and go
there wasn't any road through her
backyard and she was fairly sure that
the road on the other side was nowhere
near where that house would have to be
her own house was on the end of a short
cul-de-sac
intrigued she forgot all about the
cleaning leaving the vacuum where it lay
and went out the back door to stand on
her concrete porch
the sun was bright and scorching and she
found it hard to believe that only three
days before
the sky had been almost black at midday
the cold rain slicing down in sheets
the wind shrieking through the trees
like a demon for hours on end
keeping her wide awake and shivering
with mingled fear and anticipation
as the storm picked its painfully slow
course across the state
from this closer vantage point carolyn
could tell definitively that the white
blotch was a wall
she tramped through the yard her bare
feet slipping on the carpet of dead
leaves
and placed her hands on the top of the
fence the metal was hot
and she pulled her fingers away swearing
by leaning forward a bit and pushing
some of the thick growth aside
she saw that the wall was only a wall
and not part of a building of any sort
it was crumbling and discolored and
looked as though it had been there for
ages
longer than her house had been at first
she thought there was a rectangular hole
in the concrete block
because there was a black shape almost
dead center but by leaning farther she
determined that this was a solid
something
at this distance she couldn't quite make
it out hmm
very mysterious she said to herself
pulling back from the fence her arms
pink with thin scratches
the humid air around her was heavy with
the buzzing of machinery
she hadn't noticed the sound much for
the past day or two it had become a
constant drone like the rushing of blood
in her ears
but now it seemed very loud carolyn
trudged around the side of the house out
to the front yard
which looked even worse than the back if
that was possible
a couple of ragged rose bushes planted
by the previous owners
were struggling for life amid the
patches of sand and weeds
and a skinny palm tree that had lost
half its fronds to the storm
waved and withered in the stifling
breezes
mr tate was in his driveway next door
fiddling with a chainsaw
every now and then he'd wipe the sweat
off his forehead with a sopping blue rag
he peered up through his ungroomed gray
eyebrows as carolyn approached
hey there wondered when you'd be coming
out of hiding
i didn't want to come outside it's just
too much to deal with
he grinned and stood upright he only
came up to carolyn's chin
yeah i know how you feel you seem to
have pulled through all right though
carolyn looked back at her house which
was a trifle battered but otherwise fine
like me she thought yes how did you do
not bad wooden fence came down in the
back couple of shingles but that's it
he looked over her shoulder at her front
yard she felt like stepping into his
field of view to keep him from seeing it
i could clean that up for you when i'm
done with all this he said gesturing
behind him
i know you're not much for the outdoors
gee am i that obvious
she felt her cheeks getting warm but
thanks i'd appreciate that
for a minute she stood there with her
hands on her hips feeling the sweat
running in rivulets down the small of
her back
the street seemed alive with activity
and noise people milling about
working rubbernecking talking with one
another in awe struck tones about the
storm
about the damage left in its wake mr
tate
she said her gaze still fixed on a spot
in the distance where a fat black tree
lay horizontally across the road
blocking the traffic
that's me was there ever a house in the
woods out there in back
like out behind my fence he wiped at his
brow again and his wrinkled face turned
thoughtful
back there huh well it was before my
time if there was and i've been here
close to 40 years
why you see something back there
confronted with a direct question she
suddenly didn't want to tell him
it felt like her private knowledge a
delicious secret that she didn't want to
share
no she said as casually as she could
manage just wondering
she could tell by the look in his eyes
that he didn't believe her and she felt
bad but there was nothing for it now
well whatever he said bending down to
his chainsaw again
i wouldn't go messing around back there
if i were you probably snakes as big
around as you are
probably she started to back away moving
toward her own driveway
thanks a lot mr tate just let me know
when you want to start the cleanup i'll
come out and help you
he didn't look up at her no problem
it'll be a couple of days
she went into the house through the
front door feeling his gaze drilling
into her back
she didn't want him to see her going
around to the backyard
once inside immersed in the blissful
electrical coolness
she immediately went into the spare room
and stared out the window
the patch of white walls shone like a
beacon through the tangled trees
taunting her with its incongruity what
are you doing there mister
she whispered into the glass the
humidity outside made it appear as
though the wall had shimmered in
response
the next morning was sunday and carolyn
waited until she heard mr tate's car
coughing down the road
probably off to the grocery store to
restock the fridge before she went out
into the backyard
the night before she had rummaged
through the old shed searching for
something to clear the brush beyond the
fence
the shed had been there when she'd
bought the house and she hadn't bothered
to clean it out
she had emerged half an hour later
coated with cobwebs and sweat
smelling of old rust and paint with
nothing to show for her efforts but a
broken weed whacker
well that would have to do she certainly
wasn't going to ask anyone to borrow
anything more appropriate
clad in a long-sleeved shirt and jeans
tucked into her socks
she set out with her pathetic implement
sweltering and feeling slightly
ridiculous
she climbed up and then fell over the
chain-link fence her sneakered foot
catching in one of the gaps and sending
her sprawling
she landed with an oof of forced breath
branches clawed at her clothes
and face and a million small scurrying
creatures fled in terror from her clumsy
arrival on the other side
pretty swift carolyn she said getting to
her feet
brushing the twigs and leaves and bugs
from the seat of her pants
she picked up the weed whacker and
started hacking away
after a few minutes of fruitless
deforestation she realized that it would
probably be easier to just crawl through
the tangles instead of trying to battle
through them
she dropped the useless weed whacker and
dived into the trees
closing her eyes to keep the stray
branches from poking them out only
opening them to check her progress
the woods weren't nearly as impenetrable
as they appeared from without and in
what seemed like no time at all she
found herself standing a few feet from
the wall that had been here all along
just waiting for some disaster of nature
to come along so that it could show
itself
carolyn shuddered pleasurably at the
thought the wall didn't look quite so
white from close up
the blocks were grimy with age and the
hurricane had plastered wet leaves here
and there
like dark green post-it notes but the
most interesting thing by far
was the black something or other that
carolyn had seen from the window
at first thinking it was a small hole it
wasn't a hole though
it was a mailbox all the mailboxes on
her street and indeed in most parts of
the city
were log-shaped metal things fastened to
wooden poles that were set into the
ground beside the road
but this is one of the types seen on
older houses black and oblong and
mounted right on the outside of the
house
usually near the front door it had two
curling bits of metal at the bottom
like a pair of receiving arms where the
outgoing mail was placed
carolyn ran her finger down the side of
the metal and a few flakes of rust came
off and fluttered to the ground
it seemed weird for the mailbox to be
all that was left on this concrete chunk
of nothing that might have been a
building once
this didn't even look like the front of
the house where the mailbox would
usually be
there was no sign that there had ever
been a door or a window anywhere on the
remaining expanse
she had a sudden urge to look inside the
mailbox to check to see what kind of
letters the ghosts were receiving
dead letters she thought and shuddered
again not so pleasurably this time
for a moment she thought she felt eyes
upon her and she turned quickly her
shoes crackling in the underbrush
but there was nothing just the
crisscrossed vines and the lazy were of
insects
with the sense that she was doing
something illegal spying on someone who
just wanted to be left alone out here in
the woods
she flipped up the black metal top it
squealed so loudly that she actually
shushed it
peering around her again to make sure no
one had heard to make sure mr tate
wasn't standing there at her back fence
straining to see her through the
branches she looked inside
there was something in there down in the
dark
carolyn's body temperature seemed to
drop 20 degrees despite the broiling sun
and the thick layers of clothing
she blinked hoping she could rid herself
of the illusion of that slim bit of
paper or card
leaning against the inside of the
mailbox amid the shadows
just as if it had every right in the
world to be there
she looked again her vision cleared but
it was still there
she figured later that she probably
would have stood there forever gaping
into that little black rectangle
if she hadn't heard the roar of a car
engine close by
mr tate was back from his errand feeling
exposed and caught in the act
she slammed the lid down on the
impossible delivery and plunged into the
weeds
climbing through the brush as fast as
she could go
she dreamed that night that she went
down to her mailbox after nightfall
she couldn't see what was inside it but
she was expecting a very important
letter
and knew that it must be in there she
reached into the box and felt around
her fingers at first meeting nothing but
corrugated metal
then she felt the teeth she woke up in a
pool of cold sweat
the next day was labor day and carolyn
stumbled out of bed just as the first
yellow rays hurtled over the horizon she
didn't bother with breakfast or even
coffee but simply pulled on the stained
clothes from the day before
it was much easier going this time what
with the rough path she had made through
the woods
her watch read 705 when she stood in
front of the wall again
panting slightly the atmosphere was
already laden with moisture
making it hard to breathe not caring who
heard this time
she lifted the hinged lid of the mailbox
its cry was less severe today
remembering her dream she actually
watched her hand descend into the box
and watched it rise out again as she
pulled out what was in there
she didn't look at it she just pressed
it against her leg and hurried back to
the house
it was a postcard not an old one either
but stiff and new
coated with a shiny gloss and smelling
vaguely of ink
carolyn sat at her kitchen table stewing
in her filthy shirt and jeans
the picture on the front of the card was
of a desolate landscape she couldn't be
sure where it was maybe out in the
desert or someplace
everything was gray and misshapen and
amorphous like the melting clocks in
that dolly painting
looking at it gave carolyn a peculiar
sensation thousands of caterpillar legs
tickling her skin
she turned the card over and gasped for
scrawled there in what appeared to be a
child's hand
were the words dear carolyn
no way she said aloud and the sound of
her voice in the closed in house made
the goosebumps sweep up and down her
arms what the hell was this anyway she
studied the back of the card carefully
trying not to let her gaze fall upon
those two words scribbled there in black
felt-tip pen
but there was nothing else no copyright
notice no printers or distributors logo
no empty rectangle where the stamp was
supposed to go
and then she recalled saturday afternoon
in mr tate's driveway
when she told him there was nothing back
there in the woods and he'd given her
that little look
the one that said i don't believe you
carolyn could he have gone snooping
around
and decided to play a joke on her kind
of get her back for not trusting him
with her secret
it didn't sound likely but what other
explanation was there
she'd only just seen that wall in that
mailbox for the first time yesterday
and there was no way someone was
addressing postcards to her when no one
in the neighborhood even knew her name
except for mr tate of course the card
could have been meant for someone else
but it looked brand new
and besides how many carolines could
there be around here
sure she was only minutes from throwing
up she rose from the table and flung the
card into the trash
she suddenly needed to get out of the
house
carolyn had not intended to ever venture
over her back fence again
the broken limbs and knots of weeds
could grow like uncontrollable fungus
choking the view and burying that damned
wall again forever as far as she was
concerned
she had another nightmare worse than the
first and she woke up tuesday morning
feeling as though she'd been run over
but she went to work anyway when she got
home she didn't even bother with the
long sleeves
she just climbed the fence and pushed
into the trees in her work clothes
snagging her pantyhose and breaking a
heel there was another postcard
leaning in the shadows at the bottom of
the box it didn't surprise
her she'd been picturing the scenario
all day at work
obsessing over it until the boss had
yelled at her to stop daydreaming
this card had a similar picture on it
the gray warped landscape that looked
like the surface of some far away planet
but this one had a figure on it too far
off in the distance so that it was only
a silhouette standing on the dunes
even though she couldn't see the
figure's face or make out any
distinguishing features
carolyn still had the disturbing feeling
that it was looking at her through the
layers of ink laid down on the stiff
cardstock
she flipped the card over only one word
this time
please carolyn went back into the house
she visited the mailbox every day after
work and then on friday she didn't even
bother going to the office at all
there was a new card in the box every
day she had completely discounted the
idea that mr tate had anything to do
with this
he had come knocking on her door
wednesday afternoon asking if she was
ready to begin the cleanup on the
weekend
but she turned him away changed my mind
about it she said
i decided to do it myself he'd given her
another one of those looks and shuffled
off toward his own house next door
she hadn't seen him since all the cards
were similar except for the figure in
the picture
which was imperceptibly closer in each
shot it never occurred to carolyn to
refuse to pick up her otherworldly male
something beyond reason compelled her
made her into an automaton
she began to understand what being an
obsessive-compulsive would be like
put together the card spelled out a
message dear carolyn
please help i am all alone here please
help me
at night she would study the cards in
succession lay them out on her kitchen
table under the dim light from the 70s
style chandelier
she started to associate the person
writing with the person in the picture
all alone on the alien plains crying out
in the darkness for someone to hear
to come someone anyone carolyn
the days dragged on one fading into the
next
only the postcards distinguishing one
day from another
carolyn got fired from her job because
she never bothered to show up anymore
the fallen tree limbs out in the yard
started to rot
and every day when she went out to the
mailbox not her normal mailbox she only
checked that every third day or so
whenever she could be bothered to go
through that ritual that pale imitation
of this greater one
there would be another postcard for her
none of the others had her name on them
just the first one had the ones she'd
thrown away but she knew they were for
her
always for her at this point the figure
in the postcard stayed in the same place
and the message just kept repeating
itself over and over alone please help
the figure on the postcard looks so
forlorn yet so sinister
it was still quite far off and its face
was still just a dark shadow
a smudge of bluish gray ink it hadn't
gotten any closer for the last seven or
eight days
and carolyn didn't know what to do the
nightmares were very bad now
most nights she didn't sleep at all her
eyes were sunken into their sockets
at last one day it came to her as she
was lying in bed
stinking unable to remember when she'd
showered last
the idea struck her with such force that
she sat up in bed as though she'd been
yanked up by a string
with more zeal than she'd shown since
the postcard started coming
she hopped out of bed feeling faint for
a second because she hadn't been eating
much either
but when she'd recovered she gave
herself a quick scrub in the bathroom
sink
washing off most of the accumulated
weeks of grime
then she threw on some clothes that
looked halfway presentable and dashed
out to her car as fast as her bony legs
would carry her
mr tate was out in his yard next door
watering his lawn
he glanced up at her but otherwise
didn't acknowledge her presence
she squealed the tires as she backed out
of the driveway she felt weightless
elated
it was all going to end she was going to
end it she couldn't believe she hadn't
thought of it before
there was a big drunk store less than a
mile from her house and through the
front window she saw what she was
looking for
inside she poured through the racks of
postcards curling her lip at most of the
touristy ones
some of them were pretty they were just
wrong
finally at the bottom of the rack and
tucked behind several other postcards
with different designs
she came across what she thought was the
perfect thing
it had no text at all there was only a
picture of a woman with her back turned
to the camera
standing on a beach her blonde hair
blowing in a breeze only she could feel
the sand and sky were a warm caramel the
exact opposite of the blue gray and the
haunted postcards
and the woman even though only the back
of her head and part of her shoulder was
visible
was close to the camera close enough so
that carolyn could see the slight
dusting of sand across her golden skin
the silvery glint of her hair light and
dark
near and far she paid for the card and
rushed home
then she sat at the kitchen table for an
age with her black felt tip pen
poised over the blank white back of the
card she wasn't sure what to write
she didn't know the name of the person
or whatever who had been communicating
with her
but it seemed rude and abrupt not to
have some sort of salutation or greeting
she pondered for a long time eventually
she put pen to paper
hello what do you want me to do carolyn
she tilted her head to the side and
considered her neatly printed words
her simple response to the plea that had
drilled into the core of her being
tormenting her with all the insistence
of a bleeding wound
she actually smiled i'm answering the
call she thought
after checking it over staring at the
picture again and marveling at it an
almost flawless photo negative of the
figure in the landscape on the phantom
postcards
she pinched her reply between her
fingers and set out for the woods
intending to consign it to those waiting
wrought iron arms at the bottom of the
mailbox on that crumbling white
remainder of a wall
of a building that never was
it was late at night carolyn knew that
much the dream tonight had been the
worst ever
so horrible that she couldn't fathom how
she had not gone stark raving insane
as it unspooled on the movie screen of
her mind
in the middle of it she thought she woke
up but then thought to herself her dream
self that she couldn't have
because the dream was still there right
in front of her a rectangle of blue grey
landscape with a black figure coming
closer and closer
and calling to her with a low voice
sweet on the surface but rotten
underneath
a voice like a mouthful of grave dirt
carolyn shook herself trying to get out
to get away
but the postcard picture was enveloping
everything turning everything familiar
around her into a warped dark mockery of
itself
the figure was so close now and carolyn
could smell it
an overpowering reek of mold and decay
and the dry stench of desiccated flesh
she sat up and tried to back away
feeling the wooden headboard behind her
just like it was in her real bedroom
the one she'd see when she finally woke
up from this endless nightmare
and her thoughts were racing feverish
thinking of how long that white wall had
been back there hidden by the tangled
vines
and how long the messages had been
waiting for her just her
and then once they found her waiting for
her to answer them
and then the enormity of what she done
struck her like a megaton
warhead and she thought it kept calling
me and calling me it was calling me all
the time but i never answered it so i
was safe
but now i've answered it i've told it
who i am and where i am
and then the figure in the postcard was
very close the smell of
it so strong that she could taste it at
the back of her throat and then it
turned its head
all carolyn remembered was teeth it
seemed like millions of them like tiny
silver razors and a mouth as big as the
world
and she screamed and screamed but it
didn't do any good no one could hear her
and just before everything went black
she saw that alien landscape swallowing
the universe
making everything warp and sag and then
she was swallowed in turn
disappearing into the shifting blue-gray
sands on the other side of the wall
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she will die the harsh whisper inches
from her ear
startled leah out of the floating
semi-does that had been passing for
sleep
she blinked in the darkness instantly
wide awake and then nearly jumped out of
her skin
as a simultaneous flash crack of
lightning and thunder split open the sky
outside
the incessant pounding of the rain on
the roof was a constant den
and the main reason leah had been unable
to fall into a definitive slumber
john however seemed to be having no such
difficulty
leah turned her head on the pillow to
look at his slackened face
resenting him just a little for being
able to sleep so soundly through what
was surely the most violent storm in
decades
then she remembered the whisper that had
awakened her had she really heard it or
had she been dreaming if it hadn't been
in her mind then jon was the obvious
culprit
though he certainly didn't look as
though he had spoken didn't look as
though some nightmare was disturbing him
to the point of vocalization
as she watched his lips parted with a
soft clip
she will die he hissed again quite
clearly in a voice that was his own and
yet somehow not his own
as if he were attempting to do an
impression of someone with an odd
tremulous high-pitched warble
and not succeeding very well she will
die but not yet
soon very soon she will suffer first yes
her blood will flow just a little at
first and then more and more until she
begs for death
the lightning flashed again momentarily
throwing john's sleeping face into
ghoulish relief
his mouth was still moving forming
muttering cocoons around secretive words
that leah couldn't quite decipher
his eyes were stationary behind their
lids and his brow was unwrinkled and
serene
the stillness of his face against the
constant flapping of his mouth gave him
the aspect of a marionette
whose lips alone were controlled by a
puppeteer's strings
the effect made leah shudder a second
later thunder boomed
and darkness descended again she turned
her head to stare at the ceiling
trying not to hear the foul whispers
creeping among the bed clothes
she considered waking him and even moved
her hand to his shoulder to do it
but then reconsidered she wasn't up to
dealing with the inevitable crabbiness
and blame he'd lay upon her if he were
unable to get back to sleep
if he were tired for work in the morning
the whispering was spooky but she
decided she preferred it to the
anticipated complaining at being
awakened
softly she slid from beneath the covers
and placed her bare feet on the carpet
john still jabbered from his pillow and
every now and then a word like
flay or butcher would bob up out of the
murky stew of his ramblings
leah tiptoed across the rug pulling on
the robes she'd left draped over the
armchair
she wasn't sure why she was trying to be
quiet if jon could sleep through the
earth-shattering howls of wind and water
outside
then he could probably sleep through
anything all the same she turned the
knob slowly
and eased the door closed as she left
the bedroom
the clock in the den read 248 sighing
leah patted into the kitchen
and made herself a cup of hot chocolate
she knew she'd be up for the night
the storm didn't sound like it would be
lessening anytime soon
and besides jon's whispering had given
her the creeps
once settled back in the den with the
warmth of the mug reassuring in her
hands
she had resigned herself to wakefulness
fumbling for the remote she flicked on
the television
then cursed under her breath a couple of
thousand bucks for a new satellite dish
set up
and the storm had apparently rendered it
useless there was nothing on the screen
but dancing gray white static
it must have been a hell of a dream you
had last night leo wiped at the mirror
again roughly wondering why on earth jon
always found it necessary to shower in
water hot enough to melt lead
what even his voice sounded muffled by
the steam
you were talking in your sleep she said
trying to speak above the pound of the
shower
at least the drilling rain outside had
stopped for now though the slice of sky
visible through the window was an
ominous heavy slate
leah finished lining her lips then
studied her eyes in the half-fogged
mirror
considering she'd hardly slept she
didn't look too bad
probably no one at work would notice a
thing you were saying these awful things
she went on
almost thoughtfully i didn't catch it
all but it was pretty horrible
was it john was peering around the
shower curtain the shampoo stiffening
his hair
making it stick up into tufts like horns
on either side of his head
what did i say he didn't sound as if he
really cared but was simply trying to
make conversation
do you remember the dream she asked a
river of soapy water
streamed into his eye and he squinched
it shut nope slept like the dead
leah frowned at his choice of words she
found that she didn't really want to
tell him the specific words she'd heard
oozing out of his unconscious mouth
during the night
in the light of mourning they seemed
obscene the dream must have been really
bad
she said again wishing she hadn't even
brought it up maybe you're blocking it
out
yeah maybe he disappeared behind the
curtain again
and after a moment began to whistle
tunelessly leah finished putting on her
makeup
and went into the kitchen for coffee her
heels clicking sharply on the linoleum
john left for work about a half hour
before she did
he waved off-handedly at her as he went
out the door not bothering with a
goodbye
he'd seemed distant lately she thought
and whenever she pointed it out to him
he got defensive and irritable
so she'd stop talking about it as she
rinsed her coffee cup out at the sink
she heard him walking down the driveway
and getting into his car
and when the motor roared to life she
caught a movement out of the corner of
her eye
she looked up a curtain on the second
floor room of the house next door had
fallen back into place
that night the storms came again the
rain a solid wall of water
the lightning crackling great purple
white fingers across the sky
it was if anything worse than the night
before
leah tossed and turned unable to even
close her eyes to even meet sleep
halfway
john scolded her for her restlessness
but after five minutes he was snoring
thickly next to her
his hands twitching on his chest she
wondered how he did it
it was only a few minutes later as leah
lay on her back in the punctuated
darkness
that the whispering began again this
time in mid-sentence
out of the way the voice that was jon's
and yet not john
said soon a few days maybe dead and
buried
the pieces scattered where no one will
find them
leah began edging away from her husband
almost without realizing it
he just sounded so strange speaking
death planning murder
in a voice that could almost be that of
a malicious child
the words had the eerie sing-song
quality of a children's rhyme about them
kill her kill her kill her jon chanted
with something like glee
kill her and she will be out of the way
and when she is out of the way we will
be together
tie her up and cut her and kill her kill
her kill her
leah jumped out of bed this time almost
hoping she'd wake jon
that he would sit up and glare and
mutter darkly at her but in his own
voice the hateful one he always berated
her with
but he slept on her heart thumped an
interior rhythm nearly matching the
relentless hammer blows of thunder
outside
john's whispering continued a rising and
falling cadence in the lightless room
and leah put her hands over her ears
thinking she was being ridiculous but at
the same time wanting to block out all
hint of that horrible voice
issuing from her husband's lips moving
quickly she left the bedroom and
retreated to the den
closing all the doors tightly between
her and him the satellite was knocked
out again of course
but she left the tv on anyway calmed by
its constant movement and glow
if she stared at the static long enough
she could almost see shapes there
her imagination made solid in the
vacancy of interrupted reception
surely this couldn't go on she thought
she didn't relish the idea of being
awakened every night by john's bizarre
tirades
and she didn't want to sleep in another
room although christ knew there was
really no reason for them to share a bed
anymore
perhaps it was just nightmares he'd
never been bothered by them before
but maybe the storms were upsetting him
more than he let on and the stress was
coming out at his dreams
it seemed a reasonable proposition under
the circumstances leah stared at the
teasing roiling static
or maybe she thought maybe he's planning
to get rid of me
she sat up straight the thought had
startled her as though it had come from
somewhere outside herself
perhaps from the hypnotic luminescence
of the television screen
she glanced at the window and saw white
forks of lightning plunging toward the
earth
the whole thing was silly she told
herself shivering under her thin
robe why would jon want to kill her sure
their marriage probably wasn't in the
greatest shape
and john seemed to have lost all
interest in her both physically and
mentally
over the past few months but that didn't
necessarily mean anything
they'd been married a long time couples
got bored of each other
thunder boomed again and leah remembered
something that jon had whispered in his
sleep
when she is out of the way we will be
together
the tv screen boiled and glowed before
her eyes
was john having an affair it was
possible she supposed he went out on his
own sometimes on weekends without
mentioning where he was going
and it would explain his recent lack of
interest leah found that picturing jon
screwing around didn't upset her as much
as she thought it should
maybe she was getting bored of him too
she mused
but even if he was having an affair
would he really have to kill her to be
with his mistress
all he'd have to do was ask for a
divorce leah didn't really want to
divorce him but she was a reasonable
woman
and wouldn't fight him too hard if that
was what he wanted
she shook her head trying to derail her
current train of thought
all this speculation was idiotic jon was
just having some weird nightmares that
was all
he didn't want to kill her and he
probably wasn't even having an affair
she was simply worrying about nothing
blowing everything out of proportion
in the morning when the darkness and the
storms had abated all her musings would
seem preposterous
so thinking she snapped off the useless
tv and went back upstairs
determined to sleep in her own bed no
matter what
the day dawned grayer and wetter than
the last though at least there was some
sign that the clouds were thinning
leah had not slept at all and her eyes
felt huge and dry in their sockets
john's whispering had continued into the
night until finally she had been forced
back into the den
where she'd curled up on the loveseat
and stared at the blank television until
sunrise
john entered the kitchen whistling his
wet hair still slicked back against his
well-formed skull
his skin smelling of soap he headed for
the coffee pot
not seeming to notice his red-eyed wife
sitting at the table
still dressed in her robe you kept me
awake again last night
she told him when he'd sat down opposite
her and opened his paper
he peeked over the sports section what
talking in your sleep
all night he scowled you could have
slept in the den or the guest room
he lowered his eyes to the page again i
did go to the den
i didn't sleep though she sipped at her
orange juice
grimacing at its sourness you kept
saying that you were going to kill me
it had come out before she realized
she'd said it
john barked laughter behind the paper
i'd never get away with it i'm a crummy
liar
she knew it was meant as a joke but she
couldn't bring herself to smile
i think i'll call in sick today see if i
can get in a nap
yeah you do that john slurped up the
rest of his coffee and dropped the
sports section onto the table top
i gotta go there's a meeting this
morning and i can't be late have a good
nap
he had shouldered into his coat and was
gone before she'd registered his words
her whole body felt sluggish and heavy
yet somehow wired with
a jittery electricity her throat was
like sandpaper
not bothering to pick up the dishes or
the newspaper leah headed straight
upstairs
the events of the night before still
buzzing in her brain
she remembered thinking how everything
she'd imagined about john's affair and
his planned murder would seem silly in
the morning
but now that morning had come for some
reason all of her suspicion seemed more
plausible than ever
in the bedroom she first opened john's
dresser drawers one by one
filtering carefully through the socks
and underwear as though she was at a
sacred archaeological dig
she wasn't sure what she was looking for
but she was confident she would know it
when she saw it
if she saw anything at all the drawers
yielded nothing
so she turned her attention to the
closets jon's suits hung in fairly neat
rows off to one side
along with his few casual clothes she
searched all the pockets inside and out
and even shoved her fingers down inside
every one of his shoes
feeling around in their damp feetedness
expecting any minute for something
what a signed confession of adultery a
pair of women's panties reeking of some
perfume she never wore
to insinuate itself into her grasp
nothing did
her sleeplessness was now having the odd
effect of making her feel supernaturally
awake
aware of every tiny sound and dust mote
aware of the blood coursing through her
body
beating at her skin as if longing for
escape she felt as if she was on a
cocaine high
seeing everything in vivid detail the
edges of everything were so
sharp that they made her eyes hurt there
was something for her to find in this
house
and she was going to find it two hours
later
while tearing apart john's study she saw
it
at first she was so caught up in the
wanton destruction of john's things
so caught up in the search that she
almost tossed it aside
despite its obvious significance just as
her hand was about to pitch it away she
realized what she held
and closed her fist around it when she
opened her hand it lay on her palm
sparkling up at her innocently it was a
fragile gold
chain thin and delicate as spider silk
but obviously expensive
she looked hard at it noticing the bent
wire with the clasp had broken
the necklace was not hers she was
partial to silver jewelry when she wore
any at all
leah held the chain between two fingers
and dangled it in front of her eyes
she almost fancied she could feel the
warmth of the woman's neck that had worn
it and lost it
here in this very room in her mind she
saw
john leading an attractive young yes of
course she'd be younger wouldn't she and
blonde where leah was brunette
girl into his study the gold necklace
sparkling over the twin humps of her
clavicle
her face nothing but a pale smear in
leah's imagination
my wife will be suspicious if we go to
the bedroom john said in her vision
the carpet in here is soft enough leah
got to her feet still gripping the chain
even though she told herself last night
that the idea of john screwing around
didn't bother her much
now that she was confronted with the
reality and in my very own house he
brought her into my house
she was a mass of conflicted emotions
the strange sleepless buzz she'd been
riding all morning seemed to be ebbing
away
and now she was left with nothing but an
exhausted sense of betrayal
depression and hopelessness it was all
true
john was cheating on her and if that
much was true then maybe the rest of it
was too
but could it be john didn't seem like a
murderer callous and insensitive yes
but capable of killing his own wife as
he'd said earlier he was a crummy liar
little imagination no real passion no
verve
to be frank leah didn't really think he
had the balls to kill someone
but the dreams she reminded herself
maybe he'd suppressed his plan so deeply
that his guilt only came out in his
dreams
troubled and confused leah slipped the
necklace into the pocket of her robe and
left the study
not bothering to clean up the mess she'd
made jon would be furious when he saw
that she'd gone through his things
but she was hoping that by then he'd
have bigger problems to worry about
she decided she was going to confront
him with the necklace as soon as he got
home
the clouds had vanished by the time
john's car pulled up in the driveway
and the setting sun turned the sky a
vivid purple orange
leah had showered and dressed and even
tried to conceal the grayish bags under
her eyes with makeup
she had gotten no sleep but had spent
the afternoon envisioning scenarios
about tonight's confrontation
she now sat at the kitchen table
fidgeting in her chair
taking the gold chain out of her pocket
and placing it on the table top like an
accusation
then changing her mind and putting it
back into her pocket again
when john's key turned in the lock she
nearly screamed
he strolled into the kitchen taking off
his coat not looking at her
leah's mouth opened to speak but no
sound came out
i've got some work to do in my study
john said hooking a beer out of the
fridge with one manicured hand
don't bother with dinner i'll just grab
something later he was gone in an
instant and leah heard the study door
close and lock
she sat there with her mouth still
hanging open waiting for the inevitable
moment when he would come storming out
of his study
thundering at her about the mess about
invading his privacy
she clutched the warm gold links in her
pocket she wondered if he'd known the
necklace was there
had the woman called him at work perhaps
breathing down the line in her sultry
wheedling voice
it's a very expensive necklace and i
just can't find it anywhere did you
happen to come across it darling
with a snarl leah realized that jon
might have been the one to buy it for
her
she stealed herself for jon's return the
necklace wrapped around her fingers like
a rosary
but strangely he didn't come there was
only silence from the direction of his
study
after a few agonizing minutes leah
considered getting up and knocking at
the study door
forcing him to come out but she found
she couldn't quite do it
maybe she was a coward or maybe she just
didn't want all her worst suspicions
confirmed
she felt very tired all of a sudden
the storms had returned beating on the
walls of the house with monstrous
violence
leah had gone to bed early falling into
a deep sleep as soon as her head had hit
the pillow
the crash of thunder awakened her and
she almost cried out
she'd been having a terrifying dream
who's particular she couldn't remember
but whose sense of mortal danger was
still palpable in the room when she woke
she had no idea what time it was john
was sleeping beside her
and his whispering had reached a
feverish height of lunacy the mad babble
nearly drowning out the sounds of the
storm outside
leah leaped from the bed suddenly
terrified that he would spring out of
sleep
his eyes red and glowing with the
murderous presence of the being that
inhabited him
and that he would come toward her with
his evil child-like whispers
and that he would fall atop her and
smother her against the soft carpet
pressing his body into hers the way he
must have pressed into the faceless
woman he'd [ __ ] downstairs on the rug
in his study john lay where he was
still whispering but making no obvious
attempt to move
leah approached him cautiously wincing
at the words coming from his mouth
hating him for his indiscretions for the
horrible secrets he harbored that
somehow couldn't stay secret
she leaned over him watching his lips
move by the intermittent glow of the
lightning flashes outside
and then she grabbed his arm firmly and
shook him hard
almost hoping she'd leave a bruise
hoping she could hurt him in some petty
way
wanting to get back at him for all the
anguish he'd caused
he didn't awaken right away and so she
shook him again harder
so hard that it fell to her as though
she could pull his arm from its socket
at last he groaned and blinked staring
at her uncomprehendingly for a long
moment
then furrowing his brow a harbinger of
fury to come
what the hell he said his voice almost
normal but with a slight hint of his
shaky tremulous dream voice
i know you've been screwing around she
said right into his face
her fingers still wrapped around his
upper arm he tore himself away from her
roughly
you're crazy he said you won't get away
with this
she was backing away now her open robe
flapping around her knees
she reached into her pocket and the gold
chain was there her talisman
i know what you're planning but you
won't get away with it
john staggered out of bed tangling his
legs in the blankets and lurching toward
her
get back here he growled his bulk nearly
blending into the darkness
so that leah couldn't quite tell where
he was get back here and tell me what
the hell you're talking about
leah had reached the door her hand
caressed the knob
i know all about it i've got the proof
right here
leah he came toward her but she was out
of the bedroom and down the stairs
before he could flick on the overhead
light
she was dressed only in a short
nightgown in a robe and her feet were
bare
the sounds of the storm were so loud in
the other parts of the house that she
couldn't tell if jon was coming after
her or not
she yanked open the front door and
without hesitation plunged out into the
rain
her whole body instantly drenched her
long hair heavy and sticking in clumps
to her face and neck her clothes
clinging to her body
thunder cracked and she ducked her
shoulders instinctively
there was a light in the window of the
house next door and leah made her way
toward it
afraid to look behind her in case jon
was looming in the yard with a shotgun
or with the axe from the garage she
started to laugh at the absurdity of the
image
but it was a manic gobbling laugh that
sounded closer to a scream
she mounted the porch of the house and
began pounding on the door
she didn't know the people who lived
here every now and then in the morning
she'd seen shadows moving behind the
windows and on the day the satellite
dish was installed she'd seen a moving
van in the driveway
and movers carrying furniture inside it
didn't matter at this point who answered
the door
as long as she was with other people
she'd be safe and she could call the
police and tell them what john was
planning
they'd believe her they had to leah
heard footsteps on the other side of the
door
just before it swung open to reveal a
young redheaded woman who was a little
plump but otherwise very pretty
she smiled when she saw leah on the
doorstep her teeth very white in the
dimness
and then stood aside in motion for her
to come in
when leo was standing in the living room
dripping onto the carpet
the woman closed the door behind her
leah heard a click
as the lock was turned then a metallic
sound like a blade being pulled from a
sheath
she closed her eyes and tightened her
fist around the necklace
she will soon be out of the way the
woman said in an odd
tremulous high-pitched warble
you